thank you
this was the site the last time we came
to call China on Chile's border with
Bolivia
Tiny Town where residents were
outnumbered by tens of thousands of
undocumented migrants the majority from
Venezuela
today migrants are conspicuous by their
absence in kolcani the reason for the
change is this week's deployment of
Chile's military to the Border
called Chinese mayor applauds the move
this measure has helped to improve
security for our residents because the
Army is now allowed to examine backs do
identity checks and attain people who
enter illegally but that's not enough
the military is now patrolling illegal
entry points along Chile's nearly 900
kilometer long border with Bolivia
detaining undocumented migrants who
slipped through
but the general in charge of the
operation in this area concedes that
it's impossible to control the entire
border
already we've had to change locations
and the times we Patrol because the
migrant traffickers have Scouts who are
very organized they've been changing
their tactics
this three meter high trench was built
by Chile's previous government in an
attempt to dissuade undocumented
migrants from coming into the country
but it was to no avail now with the
deployment of the military here these
undocumented migrants are being forced
to look for more dangerous longer and
more expensive alternative routes to get
into this country all along the border
here
the Atacama Desert is dry desolate and
dangerous at night the temperature drops
below zero migrants die from the cold
and dehydration
yet they still keep coming
caught they're handed over to the police
at this border facility and then taken
to the city of ikike to a temporary
migrant facility
that and the increased patrols on this
poorest border May appease those
pressing for more control of Chile's
Frontier
but even the government concedes that
it's not a magical cure for a far more
complex humanitarian problem
see a Newman Al Jazeera called chani